[Musique]
depuis 25 ans que je travaille dans le
milieu du théâtre j'ai constaté que dans
les salles
on retrouve toujours le même type de
public 85 % de la population française
ne va pas au théâtre et les 15% qui vont
son seuil sont majoritairement
représentés sur scène
pourquoi les gens combat au théâtre est
ce que cette tare que je considère comme
populaire serait considéré comme
élitiste coûteux voire poussiéreux et
chiant pour la plupart pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'il existerait une barrière
symbolique entre les gens et le théâtre
et à ce moment là comment briser cette
barrière imaginaire si les gens vont pas
au théâtre
peut-être que la solution ne serait que
le théâtre viennent à eau alors si on
allait jouer chez eux pour réaliser ce
défi
j'ai proposé à alain grasset de m'aider
c'est l'un des précurseurs du théâtre à
domicile en france et j'ai choisi à un
territoire complètement stigmatisés par
les médias verraient comme un désert
culturel fabrique de djihadistes et
repère à dealer
j'ai pu voir le maire de sevran qui est
une ville 93 de 50 milles
qui est une des villes pauvres de france
et bien malgré ça il a été très
enthousiasmée par la proposition et il a
accepté de me donner les moyens pour la
réaliser avec des acteurs professionnels
et des artistes professionnels du réseau
national tout en étant gratuite pour les
habitants le premier la première
barrière était dépassé celle de l'argent
qui n'est quand même pas des moindres
bon maintenant il fallait relever le
défi comment trouver la première
personne qui avait accepté qu'on aille
jouer chez elle
1er mars 2011 j'arrive à ce grand
territoire que je tenais absolument pas
je dis aime la vie ce dans tous les sens
à la recherche de l'art bernard je vais
aux fêtes de la ville dans les services
municipaux dans les maisons cartier dans
les associations et par jour que j'étais
dans le quartier rouge mangard un
quartier de grands ensembles au pied
d'une tour dans une association des
dames se retrouvent pour faire de la
pâtisserie
je vois arriver une jeune femme geraghty
elle cherche un tel chaos redsnow balle
pour tester les cours de massage qu'elle
venait de prendre alors je me suis dit
tiens voilà une formule comme moi
peut-être que l ve a accepté ma
proposition
en tout cas je ne sais pas si c'est la
perspective de recevoir un spectacle
dans son salon de thé pas de débat avec
les artistes après le spectacle de
rencontrer ses voisins
oui quelques jours plus tard je me
retrouve chez lem un petit appartement
du centre-ville de ce grand pour
organiser la soirée convient qu'elle
devait inviter une vingtaine de
personnes s'est abîmé sur tous ses
voisins que le spectacle évidemment
serait gratuit et qu'il serait suivie
d'un débat et que par contre chacun vous
pouvez ramener quelque chose à voir va
longer pour finir la soirée
sympathiquement quelques jours plus tard
je reviens avec une équipe artistique on
installe au décor et au moment
d'installer le siège pour les
spectateurs je demande d'agir avis ou
fasse le point sur ses invités elle me
dit bon j'ai bien trouvé quelques amis
bien sûr qu'ils vont venir ce soir mais
j'ai pas du tout réussi avant qu'ils
aient le même voisin bon ok c'est pas
grave on va aller sonner chez eux et
nous voilà partis dans mon peuple a
sonné à tous les étages
le soir on était tellement nombreux que
j'ai passé toute la représentation collé
au mur du fond de l'appartement après le
spectacle on a eu un débat très riche et
plein d'émotion et j'ai compris pourquoi
géraldine avait accepté la thématique
abordée dans la pièce
à voir aux malades touchés
particulièrement parce que sa belle
soeur était dans cet état depuis
plusieurs années et je crois que ça
faisait beaucoup de bien pouvoir mettre
des mots sur ce silence
bon la première barrière enfin après
celle de l'argent était tombé on avait
réussi à jouer un spectacle théâtre
romain devant un auditoire calais pour
la coupe a jamais aidés au théâtre
quelques chanceux et surtout plutôt
courageux ont accepté de relever le défi
à leur tour et de prendre une
représentation chez veut se voir large
et géraldine et donc le système boule de
neige était lancée
la première a même lâché 45
représentations au théâtre à domicile à
la deuxième année 75 sa troisième année
150 et l'année dernière on a fait deux
cent quarante représentations au fur et
à mesure
[Applaudissements]
on a confiance et demande des habitants
dans le territoire de diffusion
augmenter et puis heureusement les
subventions avec on est passé de une
ville à douz ville est néanmoins la
première attaque je me suis dit c'est
formidable les gens acceptent ou
viennent jouer chez eux mais maintenant
il faudrait trouver le moyen que des
gens claire interne
comment pouvons-nous faire peut-être que
en les incluant dans le processus de
création ça changerait les choses et là
je me suis adressé à une autre géraldine
qui est artiste qui a l'habitude de
faire des spectacles participatifs
on a décidé de faire un spectacle qui
s'appelle host analyse qui parle de la
question des migrations et la gélatine
m'a dit écoute ça serait bien que 20
personnes acceptent de monter sur scène
avec les artistes du hockey et magrets
et les cherchons voilà reparti dans se
branchent plus à la recherche de gens
qui allaient vouloir accepter viennent
jouer chez eux mais j'en connais vouloir
jouer avec des comédiens sur scène de la
loire géraldine l'expliqué tout le
projet salah et nasreddine qui sort le
chanteur et le chef de choeur du
spectacle joué deux petites chansons et
moi je prenais les inscriptions la
rencontre est à peu près de 100
personnes et il ya 100 personnes qui se
sont inscrites et puis finalement non
pas
mais cinquante personnes ont accepté de
monter sur scène avec les hardis le soir
de la première puisque j'étais contente
quand j'ai vu arriver au théâtre des
gens des hommes des femmes
je venais avec des poussettes avec des
gâteaux avec des passes et comme au
théâtre à domicile on avait fait tomber
encore une autre barrière parce que ce
n'était plus le même tu lis uniforme
j'avais toujours vu dans les salles mais
vraiment un public multiples qui est le
reflet de notre diversité et enfin nous
avons ensuite après le spectacle fait un
grand poste était vraiment assez fou à
ces joyeux mais même si tout le monde
pleurait on voulait plus se quitter et
là je me suis dit ils vont vraiment on
trouve le moyen de ces artistes puissent
passer des plus longtemps sur le
territoire tout s'imprégner de la vie
des habitants
et là j'ai imaginé des cycles de
création qu'elle ait duré deux ans les
artistes allaient d'avoir venir écouter
les habitants les interviewés écrire des
pièces à partir de leurs témoignages etc
pierre la première saison allait tourner
dans le domicile des habitants et la
deuxième saison une autre équipe allait
venir faire un grand spectacle synthèse
de tout ça on allait jouer au théâtre
avec d'autres habitants
j'ai proposé aux différentes équipes de
travailler cette année là sur la
question du masculin et du féminin
chacun s'est emparé du sujet à sa
manière il y en a qui ont voulu
travailler sur les rapports mère-fils
d'autres sur les
violences conjugales d'autres encore sur
la question du travail dits féminins ou
des métiers dits masculins en tout cas
donc seulement les 3000 spectateurs on a
rencontré à domicile pendant la première
saison sont revenus la deuxième saison
voir un spectacle à la grande salle mais
surtout on avait fait tomber les
barrières
et cette fois ci du côté des artistes il
avait accepté d'écrire des pièces vont
plus à partir de leur pointu mais à
partir du point de vue des habitants
et oui c'est pas si simple que ça de
confronter son opinion à celle d'autrui
comme le dit larry les sig qui est
professeur à harvard et spécialiste de
droit sur internet avec l'avènement des
algorithmes quand on en parlait tout à
l'heure dans les réseaux sociaux on est
toujours mis face à des gens qui ont le
même profil vous donc la contradiction
n'existe plus vraiment donc il est très
important de créer des espaces citoyens
de dialogue et des changements parle
avec des gens qui n'ont pas la même
opinion peu mou il ya quelques semaines
alors qu'on était en train de terminer
la tournée de je suis une femme et je me
soigne dans les appartements à ce grand
une habitante nos ennemis j'habite un
petit quartier pavillonnaire
près du parc de la poudrerie m'appelle
et me dit d'aller lire très embêté parce
que pour la représentation de demain
soir presque tout le monde s'est désisté
il ya plus de cinq personnes et ce qu'on
a nous dit je suis passé à cause
également sous toit jeudi d'août
tout est organisé c'est quand même très
embêtant jeudi je te rappelle je vais
voir ce que je vais faire et large appel
à richard ya une autre habitant de
sevran qui habite un quartier de grands
ensembles qui s'appelle comblant et qui
a participé à l'écriture de la pièce
aïcha je lui présente aussi le problème
et elle dit écoute je vais voir ce que
je peux faire je te rappelle
deux heures plus tard richard abel et
même dit voilà j'ai trouvé 15 personnes
pour aris il attaque demain soir est-ce
que ça suffit le lendemain on s'est
retrouvés chez deux ans et demi n'a pas
peur d'ouvrir sa porte aïcha elle ne
connaissez pas et paris charles n'a pas
eu peur de venir avec ses 15 ans annie
chez nos ennemis ils sont d'ailleurs
tous arrivés avec des plats qu'ils
avaient préparées pour l'occasion le
débat qui a suivi cette représentation a
été particulièrement riche parce qu'il
mettait en dialogue des gens qui n'ont
pas du tout qui n'avait pas du tout la
même opinion sur le sujet de la pièce à
savoir les femmes
elisa tout le monde d'écouter les avis
divergent bon il faut dire qu'un buffet
polyculturelle ça l'aide à réfléchir
quelquefois mais ce jour là on avait
fait tomber encore une autre barrière on
avait réussi à
créer un espace citoyen de dialogue
entre les habitants d'ailleurs comme
cette expérience a été spécialement
probante
on a décidé qu'à partir de la rentrée on
allons proposer aux habitants qui
habitent des quartiers différents de
l'ordre d'organiser l'ensemble des
représentations chez eux
bon tout ça vient de la confiance qui
s'est établi au fur et à mesure des
années entre les habitants les artistes
et la petite équipe qui s'est formée
autour de moi c'est un travail de fourmi
mais maintenant quand le dernier
collectif d'artistes qui vient d'arriver
sur le territoire pour être en immersion
totale avec les habitants demandent
d'aller dormir chez eux et bien c'est
immédiatement possible
tout ça n'a pas été simple
toutes ces barrières n'ont pas été
simples allez passer de toute façon je
pense qu'il y en aura d'autres et puis
c'est vrai on n'a pas l'habitude de se
mélanger ni dans les salles de théâtre
ni dans les réseaux sociaux ni dans les
quartiers on reste tous entre soi parce
qu'on a tous nos peurs nos préjugés nos
certitudes mais à l'heure où la montée
des extrémismes en tous genres gagne je
crois qu'il est important voire même
peut être vital d'accepter d'ouvrir
sa cohorte vous discutez pour ouvrir le
dialogue avec l'autre moi je les fais
avec le moyen qui est le mien le théâtre
et vous voyez que c'est possible puisque
depuis les vingt spectateurs
on a rencontré chez géré a dit dans la
première représentation
on a bientôt ouvert le dialogue avec
20000 spectateurs
[Applaudissements]
parmi les spectateurs qui ont accepté
d'être bousculé et parfois même
transformé alors vous demain avec game
moyens vous pourriez ouvrir le dialogue
merci